Hey guys, Gigguk here with another useless video...
So if you've been hanging around YouTube or Twitter, you may have seen these TIER LISTS pop up.
I-I don't know you might have missed them. Only about two people have done it at this point. It-It's pretty new.
But while we have fast foods, and presidents, and Youtubers,
Where is the tier list us weebs really care about?
That's right!
CUTE ANIME GIRLS!
So today I'll be taking some of the most popular female characters I can find on MyAnimeList
and some relevant seasonal ones and just a few wild cards for good measure!
Of course someone like me who has immersed himself in a study of waifuology...
I will persevere to give the most objective,
impartial list that will leave out all my personal biases, and-
*pop*  OHHOHO- WOULD YOU- WOULD YOU LOOK AT THIS?!?! SENJOUGAHARA'S S-TIER. WHO COULD'VE- LOOK!
Who could've seen that coming, but I mean starting with my literal goddess would be a bit unfair, so...
You know if there was one character that could set the baseline for this list, it would be...
Asuna.
If there was a gamer girl of waifus, she would be IT.
Hell. She IS a gamer girl.
This is kind of as basic an anime girl as you can get. It's like starting a new game and in the character creation screen
You picked the default character model and-
DON'T EDIT ANY OF THE BASE STATS
Her only outstanding feature is the fact that
she doesn't have any outstanding features. D Tier.
Shinobu.
Anime has garnered this uncomfortable reputation for
having these characters that look
Suspiciously young actually be obscenely old and mature of
vampires or demon lords trapped in a younger body.
Only those with an untrained eye will fail to recognize that Shinobu is clearly...
FIVE HUNDRED AND NINETY EIGHT YEARS OLD.
And that's why cultured men like us can put her A Tier and not feel weird about anything at all,
Cuz we don't.
This is normal.
I swear to god.
Your honor.
Zero-Two.
Here's the prime example of a girl who has topped the charts from the
aesthetics quality while forgetting to put any of the stats back into the character.
If we were going by design alone,
she would have easily been best girl of 2018.
She's got the unique look, the unique quirks.
I'm pretty sure she's the only waifu that can claim to be a spaceship!
But it says a lot about how strong these traits are which can go from "Crazy-murderous-rampage" to
"Non-existent-character" and can still be Best Girl in your show that we haven't forgotten.
B Tier.
Akame from Akame ga Kill.
more like edgy enough to make me akame go kill myself... (E tier btw)
Ichigo.
Now Ichigo gets a lot of hate for having the audacity to compete...
but I think she has some positives going for her
I mean just imagine waking up to this face next to you every morning.
And personally,
I can't think of a better way to start my day because then...
I already know the day couldn't get any worse.
Black hole Chan.
This is what happens when you take any kind of monumental scientific achievement and...
give it to the anime community to completely be ruined.
Here we have a girl who has the massive 6.5 billion suns concentrated into a point so dense
it has a gravitational pull that can physically distort space-time. So you can see what's so special about black hole chan,
she's very much into vore.
She loves vore.
THIS IS VORE-
Personally I think we found a new fetish of a girl
That'll suck so hard even after you nut,
She'll just keep sucking until...
Every atom that makes you up gets ripped apart...
At a subatomic level
.....................................................................................
DON'T KINK-SHAME ME!
Why tier
Evangelion girls - you've got to pay respect to the classics and Asuka is a true OG that holds a close place in my teenage heart
She pioneered tsunderes and there are a few even today that can hold a candle to her
They say you'd never forget your first but as you grow older you move on and become wiser
Some say you realize you're an adult when you start taking responsibility for your own actions
however
the true sign of
Adulthood is when you live as an Asuka kind of kid, only to grow up and realize that you've become a Misato
man. Rei though still remains the Eva girl equivalent of stepping in a wet pile of wood with socks on. Rem - now I know i've memed
Up Rem a lot, but even I can see how she got the popularity that she did
I mean, she's a sweetheart. She sticks with you and she'll lift you up during your darkest times
So right here, I think she should get a bit of the recognition that she deserves
*I LOVE EMILIA*
wha?
Hinata.
I got to be honest, I'm not the biggest fan of this character archetype the shy lovestruck girl
That only comes out of their shell to the person they like I think the technical term is "dandere,"
but I much prefer the term doormat
however
I have to give her credit because she is one of the only
short bluehaired anime girl that has ever ended up with the guy they liked because she
persevered and was true to her feelings and protected her love in the hardest of times and MOST IMPORTANTLY,
she grew her hair out.
proving that all doormats can dream of one day growing up to
BECOME CARPET.
Ochako from my Hero Academia.
Ochako is a good, hard-working girl.
All she wants to do is to make money so she can take care of her parents!
How straight-foward is that!?
She is the definition of a pure cinnamon roll.
And that's why I'm gonna put her in the Panera bread Tier. (Excuse me, she is CLEARLY Cinnabon tier.)
Megumi Tadokoro.
She's like Ochako, but just not as refined a pastry and
What's a less elegant cinnamon roll?
That's right, a sausage roll.
Gregg's Tier.
Hina and Rui.
Winter season's domestic girlfriend really put to test the eternal battle in waifu trash.
Imotous vs Onee-samas.
Little Sis vs Big Sis.
Onii-chan vs Ara Ara?
Whatever your preference,
don't forget the die-hard rule to live by when talking about siblings in anime.
If she's not blood-related, she's free to be dated. (Speech 100)
C Tier.
Jabami Yumeko.
I once said don't stick your dick in crazy
And Jabami is fucking crazy
Any sane person can see that.
So any guy who could actually try something with her would obviously only be able to think with their dicks
Fortunately, my dick, has an IQ, of 200.
Senko-san.
Senko-san takes up the role of seasonal waifu that you end up
seeing everywhere because of their reaction faces.
She's got the pout face,
She's got the blush face, and
You've got the HOLY GRAIL OF ALL ANIME REACTION FACES....
The ahegao-
(╯°□°)╯︵ ┻━┻
THE SMUG FACE!
*laughs in the background*
get it??? That's-That's why man
This makes them a prime target for anime profile pictures because they can make people think that they embody the spirit of a cute anime girl
Not realizing that it doesn't actually mask over their degeneracy and anything they say online will now never be taken seriously.
However, these girls are only really a strong pick until the season ends, at which point they then get immediately disposed of.
C Tier.
And up next we have-
Senko-san: OKARI NANO JA!
*We interrupt this video to bring special news: SENKO-SAN IS EVOLVING!*
???:OKAMI NA JOU SAI!
*EVOLVING COMPLETE!*
AH FUCKING SWEET!
This is what a true waifu goddess looks like and with that evolution her stats have totally put her up into S Tier.
Sagiri. *Calls FBI*
Okay, let me be real for a second.
I owe a lot to Sagiri, and...
and I know I said I would stay un-biased but...
In the end, Eromanga-sensei was one of my first big memes that got me quite popular, and
Sagiri was right in the middle of that.
So FBI memes aside, on a personal level,
There's only one place...
I could really put her-
*Into the trash can, meaning she's Trash Tier*
Haruhi Suzumiya.
Imagine being so desperate for friends that
the only reason anyone hangs out you is to...
Prevent the fucking apocalypse.
Chika.
This is the closest thing in anime you'd find to a drug addiction.
If you're having a bad day,
You just inject this shit right into your veins and for a moment,
It can make you forget about the drudging monotony
that is your life. Despite being a seasonal girl,
I think she's left a strong enough impression to be B Tier.
Mari from Itadaki Seieki--
*silence*
*cough cough*
*More silence*
*HentaiHaven Tier*
Rin Tohsaka.
Rin will always be one of the greats because, to me,
Rin enbodies the highest quality a tsundere can be,
while still being a pure tsundere.
Some of these top tier girls have tsun traits and tsun moments that are blended with other things...
but Rin is an out-and-out tsundere that manages to differentiate herself from the rest.
She is what happens when every tsundere trait is refined to the highest degree.
She has the twin tails,
She has the thigh-highs,
She has the blush that
I'd literally die and reincarnate into another world to protect.
And the mix between tsun and dere so perfectly balanced,
she alone could have been the most effective weapon against Thanos' snap.
S Tier.
Kaori. Spoilers for Your lie in April.
You know how in anime characters will stereo-typically wait for like
Two seasons before holding hands and like,
five years to confess?
Well Kaori here is so extra in her patience to let her true feelings known,
That by the time she decided to confess...
SHE WAS FUCKING DEAD!
She gets a D for
Speedwagon.(YES)
every so often you come across someone that has it all.
The looks,
The charm,
The loyalty....
Speedwagon embodies everything a waifu should be and more.
But I know what you're thinking.
How can this 200-pound hunk of pure man meat count as a waifu?
And that's so short-sighted!
Because you fail to see....
That waifuism...
Is in the heart.
Here's a bro that will give you the devotion you deserve
More than any other waifu could.
He will never leave you, he isn't gay.
He simply ran out of women that were worthy....
You like Speedwagon?
What kind of man doesn't?
Easily an S Tier.
and that was pretty much everyone had time for right now. If you disagree with anything I said, um yeah
It's p-probably cuz you're wrong, uh, be sure to tune in next week when you can see my scheduled apology video.
Hey guys, hope you enjoyed that video
thank you very much this month to Mike Elfen, Sisters10086, Eliphal,
Robert Harnborg, Basel, Laioken, and everyone else on my patreon for helping to support me for this month and making this video possible.
Just a reminder that I will be guesting at momo con at the end of this month
So if any of you are in Atlanta
And are going on the last weekend of May then I look forward to see you there. By the way it's actually the weekend before
my birthday so if you see me hanging around the bar, just feel free to get me a drink. So funny thing,
I actually recorded this video last week, and I couldn't get it finished in time before I started traveling
So I'm actually a momo con right now
So if you see me around the corner you at momo con,
feel free to come say hi. And you can also check my twitter @giggukAZ for any updates on any schedules and
signings and panels I'm doing. Anyway, that's it for me. I've been gigguk and I'll see you all next time.